we found a whole hamburger a whole ham
and cheese sandwich and a perfect Apple
in the trash over there from like 30
minutes ago
[Music]
we just had always thought it when we
found out that 50% of what we found was
food waste
it could be composted but it's been a
landfill and 25% of it could have gone
to the recycling then this
so we decided to create a giraffe to
make a change so we're the trash - girl
yeah
I'm Sofia I'm serenity I'm London
assorted we're trash so because we've
been so annoyed with our trash system at
school we have been working with our
environmental science teacher mister
sapin to figure out ways to reduce waste
and make students aware of proper waste
disposal so we're gonna have some
students right now we have sebastian i'm
anthony and they're gonna be sitting by
different bins in the lunchroom and like
monitoring when people dispose of their
waste every time a student disposes of
waste the right way they're gonna get
community service hours at our school we
need a hundred hours it won't get a
little
take it every time they dispose of the
waste they get 12 minutes pretty good
game right yeah 12 minutes per ticket so
even if people don't want to be good to
the environment we're basically gonna
make them and giving them every service
hours after that so original basically
Sebastian and Anthony they're working to
recruit more people this is step one of
our environmental science waste
management adventure yes we're getting
all set up for our assembly tomorrow
where we're gonna introduce all of our
new concepts and everything we've been
working on so everyone we got the best
they can
they anticipated but that's even better
because we can start implementing
new ideas even
so what we're talking about
we're gonna just talk about how since
the green bins are here we can finally
put things where they belong
oh so recycling landfill and compost
and we're having a bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how do you like certain ways I've never
done this before it's fun I mean I get
to do something I never do so work was
assembly and I think they went pretty
well now we gotta touch base with Mandy
using administrate administrator and she
was helping us with trash trash and she
one must go to board meeting to get
support from the people that run our
school I guess and we want dem shoes we
[Music]
so we put systems in place to help
reduce the waste at our school and we've
created a trash bash so that we can
actually go through all the trash and
see if all these methods we
women have been working and just make
sure that we're on track to continue to
reduce waste we're gonna make trash bash
for the stairs because our trash bash
next Wednesday their first one so we
wanna advertise it so we're putting up
our posters now our beautiful posters
and we're super excited about it
look look at cute that is so okay so
it's horrible and then the butterfly
it's a few is eating a carrot with like
the stem and ever holding the carrot I
love to throw it fast
wrong side way I love putting
conventionally and if you do it wrong
that's what happens to you
Sebastian what are you guys doing we're
going to Train campus AIDS on how to
properly sort the trash and where
everything goes go through the extras
right now oh that's nice it's not good
no okay I'm sitting here I'm trying to
start trashing living in the trash yeah
so you're relating to the trash you
understand that vanish no that's cool
sorry we're doing our first trash bash
event we are weighing the trash so that
when we sort out what's recycling in
compost we can see what of what was
disposed in the trash is actually trash
[Applause]
[Music]
so today we sorted through 18 pounds of
trash which is only a small sample of
our whole school's trash the whole
weight of all of the landfill that we
got from today was 18 pounds but 11
pounds of what went in the landfill
belonged in the landfill 3 pounds of it
was recycling that could have been
recycled and four pounds belonged in the
compost that was put in the landfill
when you take it to consideration it's
only been like a month and a half since
we've really started pushing our
movement I feel like that's pretty darn
good we were emailing back and forth and
we're gonna meet with our lunch provider
to see if we can come up with a more
environmentally friendly option and that
will reduce the waste on our campus by a
lot - we were wondering if there could
potentially be a more environmentally
friendly
solution solution - like how to put the
lunches we were thinking like maybe like
reusable containers in society that if
you will get into a family-style kind of
metal and train your staff with food
angular certification that would have a
lot so if we were going to pursue the
family-style serving perhaps we could
extend our steward program that we
already have going and get a group of
high school students to be the food
handlers and have them certified and
they can help serve the food I'm you
know I'm totally Wiggins you know I can
come here and you know like I really
like I think that it's just a really
great way to help the environment I'm
absolutely in awe of the trash bash crew
shout out the trash brush crew thanks
mia's have a a hand
we had trash bags two days ago
now we're gonna take down our signs just
kind of sad but we're planning on doing
a few more as the year goes on it's
bittersweet
yeah tell me how has the steward program
evolved over the past few minutes it's
definitely evolved a lot especially when
we first started we only had it was only
happening I don't love when people
enjoyed so it's not just us we have
around 10 stewards and during a bunch
each steward is stationed around every
single possible on trash disposal area
in just one and a half months we've
reduced the waste sent to landfill by
50% we're sorting our correctly now by
80%
I'm really proud of that they've taken
this dirty disgusting activity and said
hey this is important and felt that
Robbie toss to take this issue and run
fit
[Music]
[Music]